Tampoco se debe tomar nada de lo que digo
como justificación de la violaciones de los derechos humanos,
como las sentencias de muerte masivas
en Egipto a principios de esta semana.
Lo que estoy diciendo
es que debemos desafiar estos movimientos fundamentalistas musulmanes
porque amenazan los derechos humanos
en contextos de mayoría musulmana,
y lo hacen de muchas formas diferentes.
más evidentes por los grupos armados que llevan a cabo
los ataques directos contra civiles.
Pero esa forma de violencia es solo la punta del iceberg.
Estos movimientos, como toda forma de discriminación
contra las minorías religiosas y las minorías sexuales,
tratan de restringir la libertad religiosa
de cualquiera que practique de una manera diferente
u opte por no practicar.
Y más claramente, lideran una guerra total
contra los derechos de las mujeres.
Ahora, frente a estos movimientos
en los últimos años, el discurso de Occidente
ha ofrecido frecuentemente
dos respuestas erróneas.
La primera que uno encuentra a veces a la derecha,
sugiere que la mayoría de los musulmanes son fundamentalistas,
o que algo en el Islam es inherentemente fundamentalista.
Esto es ofensivo y falso.
Pero, por desgracia, en la izquierda uno a veces encuentra
un discurso políticamente correcto
pero que no conoce el problema del fundamentalismo musulmán en absoluto
o, peor aún, que lo disculpa.
Y esto es igualmente inaceptable.
Así que lo que estoy buscando es una nueva forma
de hablar de todo esto,
que esté basada en las experiencias vividas
y las esperanzas de la gente en los frentes de batalla.
Estoy dolorosamente consciente de que existe
un aumento de la discriminación contra los musulmanes en los últimos años,
en países como el Reino Unido y los EE. UU.,
lo que también es un motivo de gran preocupación.
Pero creo firmemente
que contar estas historias de lucha contra el estereotipo
de las personas de origen musulmán
que han enfrentado a los fundamentalistas
y han sido sus principales víctimas,
es también una gran manera de contrarrestar esa discriminación.
Así que ahora permítanme presentarles
a cuatro personas cuyas historias
tuve el gran honor de relatar.
Faizan Peerzada y el taller teatral Rafi Peer,
llamado así por su padre,
ha promovido durante años las artes escénicas
en Pakistán.
Con el auge de la violencia yihadista,
comenzaron a recibir amenazas
de cancelar sus eventos, a las que negaron prestar atención.
Y entonces un bombardero atacó su
octavo Festival de Artes Escénicas en Lahore en 2008,
produciendo una lluvia de vidrios
que cayeron en el lugar
e hirieron a 9 personas.
Más tarde, esa misma noche,
los Peerzadas tomaron una decisión muy difícil:
anunciaron que su festival
continuaría como estaba previsto para el día siguiente.
Como dijo Faizan en el momento,
si nos inclinamos ante los islamistas,
quedaremos relegados a un rincón oscuro.
Pero ellos no sabían lo que iba a suceder.
¿Vendría alguien?
De hecho, miles de personas salieron el día siguiente
para apoyar las artes escénicas en Lahore.
Y esto emocionó y a la vez
aterrorizó a Faizan,
quien corrió hacia una mujer
que había entrado con sus dos hijos pequeños,
y le dijo: "¿Ud. sabe que hubo una bomba aquí ayer,
y sabe que hay una amenaza para hoy aquí?".
Y ella dijo: "Lo sé,
pero yo vine a su festival
con mi madre cuando yo tenía la edad de ellos,
y todavía tengo esas imágenes en mi mente.
Tenemos que estar aquí".
Con audiencias incondicionales de este tipo,
los Peerzadas fueron capaces de concluir
su festival en la fecha prevista.
Y entonces el siguiente año,
perdieron todos sus patrocinadores
debido al riesgo de seguridad.
Cuando me reuní con ellos en 2010,
estaban en medio del primer evento posterior
que pudieron ofrecer en el mismo lugar.
Ese fue el noveno Festival juvenil de artes escénicas
celebrado en Lahore en un año en que esa ciudad
ya había experimentado 44 ataques terroristas.
Fue cuando los talibanes paquistanís
habían comenzado su persecución sistemática
de las escuelas de niñas que culminaría
con el ataque a Malala Yousafzai.
¿Qué hacían los Peerzadas en ese momento?
Organizaban teatro escolar para niñas.
Tuve el privilegio de ver "Naang Wal",
un musical en idioma punjabi,
en que las niñas de la escuela secundaria de Lahore
representaban todos los papeles.
Cantaron y bailaron,
actuaron de ratones y de búfalos de agua,
y yo contenía la respiración, preguntándome,
si podríamos llegar al final
de este increíble espectáculo.
Y al llegar al final, todo el público
exhaló colectivamente,
y unas pocas personas en realidad lloraron,
y luego llenaron el auditorio
con el estruendo pacífico de sus aplausos.
Y recuerdo que pensé en ese momento
que los atacantes habían sido noticia aquí
dos años antes.
Pero esa noche y esa gente
son historias igualmente importantes.
Maria Bashir es la primera y única
fiscal general mujer en Afganistán.
Ella ha estado en el cargo desde 2008
y de hecho abrió una oficina para investigar
los casos de violencia contra las mujeres,
que según ella es el área más importante
en su mandato.
Cuando me encontré con ella en su oficina en Herat,
entró rodeada de
4 hombres grandes con enormes armas.
De hecho, ahora tiene 23 guardaespaldas,
porque ha capeado ataques con bombas
que casi matan a sus hijos,
y amputaron la pierna de uno de sus guardias.
¿Por qué sigue?
Ella dice con una sonrisa, que esa es la cuestión
que todo el mundo le pregunta.
Como ella dice, "¿Por qué te arriesgas a no vivir?"
Y es simplemente que para ella,
un futuro mejor para todas las María Bashirs por venir,
vale la pena el riesgo.
Ella sabe bien que si la gente como ella
no corre riesgos,
no habrá un futuro mejor.
Más adelante en la entrevista,
la fiscal Bashir me dice lo preocupada que está
por el posible resultado
de las negociaciones del gobierno con los talibanes,
las personas que han estado tratando de matarla.
"Si les damos un lugar en el gobierno"
pregunta, "¿quién protegerá los derechos de las mujeres?"
Y ella insta a la comunidad internacional
a no olvidar su promesa sobre las mujeres
porque ahora quieren la paz con los talibanes.
Unas pocas semanas después de que dejé Afganistán,
vi un titular en Internet.
Un fiscal afgano había sido asesinado.
Consulté en Google desesperadamente,
y por suerte me enteré ese día
de que María no había sido la víctima,
cuando por desgracia, otro fiscal afgano
fue asesinado a tiros cuando se dirigía a trabajar.
Y cuando oigo titulares como este ahora,
creo que, a medida que las tropas internacionales
salgan de Afganistán este año y los siguientes,
tendremos que seguir cuidando
lo que les sucede a las personas de allí,
a todas las Maria Bashirs.
A veces todavía oigo su voz en mi cabeza
diciendo, sin bravuconadas de ningún tipo,
"La situación de las mujeres en Afganistán
será mejor algún día.
Debemos preparar el terreno para esto,
incluso si nos matan".
No hay palabras adecuadas
para denunciar a los terroristas de Al Shabaab
que atacaron el Westgate Mall en Nairobi
el mismo día de un concurso de cocina para niños
en septiembre de 2013.
Mataron a 67, incluyendo poetas y mujeres embarazadas.
Allá lejos, en el medio oeste estadounidense,
tuve la fortuna de conocer somalíes-estadounidenses
que trabajaban en contrarrestar los esfuerzos de Al Shabaab,
de reclutar a un pequeño número de jóvenes
en su ciudad, en Minneapolis,
para participar en atrocidades como Westgate.
El estudiante Abdirizak Bihi
sobrino Burhan Hassan de 17 años de edad,
fue reclutado aquí en 2008,
comprometido con Somalia
y luego fue asesinado tratando de volver a casa.
Desde ese momento, el Sr. Bihi,
que dirige el Centro para la educación y la defensa somalí, sin ingresos,
ha venido denunciando el reclutamiento
y los fracasos del gobierno
y las instituciones somalíes-estadounidenses
como el Centro Islámico Abubakar As-Saddique,
donde él cree que su sobrino se radicalizó
durante un programa juvenil.
Pero no se limita a criticar a la mezquita.
También acusa al gobierno
por su incapacidad de hacer más
para evitar la pobreza en su comunidad.
Dada su falta de recursos financieros,
el Sr. Bihi ha tenido que ser creativo.
Para contrarrestar los esfuerzos de Al Shabaab,
para influir en los jóvenes más resentidos,
a raíz de los ataques del grupo en 2010
a los espectadores de la Copa Mundial en Uganda,
organizó un torneo de baloncesto en Ramadán
en Minneapolis, como respuesta.
Decenas de niños somalíes-estadounidenses salieron
a abrazar el deporte
a pesar de la fatua contra ellos.
Jugaron baloncesto
como Burhan Hassan nunca lo haría de nuevo.
Por sus esfuerzos, el Sr. Bihi ha sido condenado al ostracismo
por la dirección del Centro Islámico Abubakar As-Saddique,
con el que solía tener buenas relaciones.
Él me dijo: "Un día vimos al imán en la televisión
llamándonos infieles y diciendo:
"Estas familias están tratando de destruir la mezquita".
Esto está en contradicción completa
con la forma como Abdirizak Bihi entiende
lo que él está tratando de hacer
mediante la denuncia al reclutamiento de al Shabaab,
para salvar la religión que yo adoro,
de un pequeño número de extremistas.
Ahora quiero contarles una última historia.
La de una estudiante de derecho de 22 años de edad en Argelia,
llamada Amel Zenoune-Zouani
que tenía los mismos sueños de una carrera legal,
como yo tuve en los años 90.
Ella se negó a renunciar a sus estudios,
a pesar de que los fundamentalistas
luchaban contra el Estado argelino en ese entonces,
amenazando a todos los que continuaran su educación.
El 26 de enero de 1997, Amel subió al autobús
en Argel, donde estudiaba
para ir a casa y pasar la noche del Ramadán
con su familia.
Nunca llegaría a terminar sus estudios de derecho.
Cuando el autobús llegó a las afueras
de su ciudad natal, fue detenido
en un puesto de control por los hombres
del Grupo Islámico Armado.
Portando su mochila,
Amel fue bajada del bus
y asesinada en la calle.
Los hombres le cortaron el cuello
y luego le dijeron a todo el mundo,
"Si van a la universidad,
el día llegará en que vamos a matarlas a todas,
igual que a ella".
Amel murió exactamente a las 5:17,
lo sabemos, porque cuando cayó en la calle,
su reloj se rompió.
Su madre me mostró el reloj
con la manecilla aún dirigida
con optimismo hacia arriba
hacia un 5:18 que nunca llegaría.
Poco antes de su muerte,
Amel había dicho a su madre,
y a sus hermanas,
"Nada nos va a pasar a nosotras, Inshallah, si Dios quiere.
Pero si algo sucede,
deben saber que morimos por aprender.
Tú y papá deben mantener su cabeza bien alta".
La pérdida de una mujer tan joven es insondable.
Y al hacer mi investigación
me encontré a mí misma en busca de la esperanza de Amel de nuevo.
Su nombre incluso significa "esperanza" en árabe.
Creo que la he encontrado en dos lugares.
El primero es en la fuerza de su familia
y todas las otras familias que siguen contando sus historias
y que siguen con sus vidas a pesar del terrorismo.
De hecho, la hermana de Amel, Lamia, se sobrepuso a su dolor,
fue a la escuela de leyes,
y practica como abogada hoy en Argel,
algo que solo es posible
porque los fundamentalistas armados
fueron derrotados en gran parte del país.
Y el segundo lugar en el que encuentro la esperanza de Amel
está en todas partes en que las mujeres y los hombres
continúan desafiando a los yihadistas.
Debemos apoyar a todos aquellos que en honor de Amel
continúan esta lucha por los derechos humanos en la actualidad,
como la "Red de mujeres bajo leyes musulmanas".
No es suficiente, ya que el defensor de los derechos de las víctimas,
Cherifa Kheddar, me dijo en Argel,
que no basta con combatir el terrorismo.
También debemos cuestionar el fundamentalismo,
porque el fundamentalismo es la ideología
que sirve de soporte a este terrorismo.
¿Por qué será que la gente como ella, al igual que todos los demás,
no son más conocidos?
¿Por qué será que todo el mundo sabe quién era Osama bin Laden
y tan pocos conocen a todos los
que enfrentan a los bin Laden en su propio ambiente?
Tenemos que cambiar eso, por lo que les pido que
por favor ayuden a compartir estas historias
a través de sus redes.
Miren de nuevo el reloj de Amel Zenoune,
congelado para siempre.
Y ahora por favor miren su propio reloj
y decidan que este es el momento en que uds. se comprometen
a apoyar a personas como Amel.
No tenemos derecho de guardar silencio sobre ellos,
porque es más fácil,
o porque la política occidental es también deficiente.
Porque las 5:17 aún están por venir
a demasiadas Amel Zenounes
en lugares como el norte de Nigeria,
donde los yihadistas siguen matando estudiantes.
El tiempo de hablar en apoyo de todos aquellos
que pacíficamente desafían el fundamentalismo
y el terrorismo en sus propias comunidades,
es ahora.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)